coinbase yesterday brian armstrong came
out last night after hours uh and said
coinbase has secured board approval to
add 500 million dollars of crypto
currencies to its balance sheet and
moving forward it will also invest 10
percent of its future quarterly profits
into digital assets they will become the
first publicly traded company to hold
ethereum proof of stake assets defy
tokens and many other crypto assets as
well
along with bitcoin so they already have
some bitcoin on the balance sheet they
went to the board they got approval 500
million dollars it's one of the bigger
purchases we've seen they are going to
buy some bitcoin along with these other
assets and then moving forward 10
of future quarterly profits they will go
ahead and they will invest into
cryptocurrencies the way they're going
to determine which cryptocurrencies they
buy is they are going to look at the
aggregate custodial crypto balances so
when people come in and they put crypto
in their custody service they'll look at
the percentages if 50 is bitcoin 20 is
ethereum 30 is everything else they'll
buy 50 bitcoin 20 ethereum 30 everything
else so when you start to think about
this there's two major moves here one
500 million dollars of your balance
sheet plus 10 of future profits this is
a model that i think more and more
companies in the future in the public
markets are going to pursue you now have
to have a bitcoin and crypto strategy
for your balance sheet bitcoin is uh
kind of the entry into the industry i
think it is inevitable that other
companies will put other assets on their
balance sheet but bitcoin will always
kind of be that first entry point on top
of that when you start thinking about
the commitment for a certain percentage
of future profits regardless of if
somebody pays in bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies or they pay in u.s
dollars coinbase will convert it into
digital assets and so what you're slowly
seeing is you're seeing an inflection
point where more and more companies are
going to start to convert their
electronic q-sip assets things like the
electronic dollar into digital assets it
would be very fascinating to see how
much of this is going to be stable coins
along with bitcoin ethereum or others
now there are many other companies that
hold bitcoin only on their balance sheet
microstrategy tesla square marathon
digital coinbase hud 8 mining galaxy
digital etc and coinbase is a very big
business so over a 50 billion dollar
market cap q2 revenue was 2.2 billion
net profit in q2 was 1.6 billion which
was up almost 50 times from a year
before
some of their top clients include elon
musk spacex tesla
and 10 of the 100 largest hedge funds
their q2 trading volume was 462 billion
dollars about 25 or so of that total
trading volume was concentrated in
bitcoin and so when you start to think
about the future of a public company's
balance sheet or the treasury management
no longer are companies going to be
falling over themselves trying to buy
bonds or other types of assets that have
a negative real rate of return they are
having to figure out something else they
cannot allow their treasury to be eroded
away from a purchasing power standpoint
michael saylor the
giga chad of all bitcoiners who has
bought billions of dollars of bitcoin
for his business and hundreds of
millions of dollars personally come came
out last year and when he did he said i
am buying bitcoin because i want to
preserve the purchasing power of my
balance sheet now what coinbase is doing
that is a little bit different is
they're not only doing bitcoin uh
exclusively they're also the first to
hold ethereum and other types of assets
i can only imagine what the compliance
legal and accounting conversations were
like in order to get this approved we
have the cfo a quote from alicia haas
who says quote we may increase our
allocation over time as the crypto
economy matures
we believe that in the future more and
more companies will hold crypto assets
on their balance sheet we hope by
incorporating more crypto assets into
our own corporate financial practices we
can take another step towards building a
more open crypto economy now again what
we expect is companies in this space
companies like square microstrategy
coinbase et cetera of course they are
going to have a propensity to be the
first to do this but all of a sudden we
are moving from a world where it was
micro strategy you had the shot heard
round the world in kind of a one-off
situation so now this is becoming
normalized and people were just like of
course that was going to happen and so i
think that when you look at something
like brian armstrong's tweets yesterday
he said we recently received board
approval to purchase over 500 million of
crypto on our balance sheet to add to
our existing holdings so this is not
brand new they already have some
and we'll be investing 10 of all profit
going forward i expect this percentage
to keep growing over time as the crypto
economy matures hopefully we can operate
more of our business and crypto today is
still a mix now what this ultimately is
signaling to me is that brian armstrong
is saying today their business is some
us dollars some electronic cash some
kind of legacy system and some of the
new world eventually the holy grail for
business like coinbase or another large
crypto economy business is to be a
hundred percent into digital assets now
when you have a platform that supports
so many different assets
it is natural for you not just to hold
bitcoin right there's a part of your
business that is in these other assets i
think two pieces of this that become
very fascinating one if a business is
solely looking to protect purchasing
power they're solely looking for a
treasury management system i think that
bitcoin is still going to be the uh
decision that's going to be the point
where people say okay do we want to
essentially buy digital gold do we want
to hold on to this and preserve our
purchasing power bitcoin will be the
solution if a company says actually you
know what we need revenue generation we
need to be able to get some sort of
return on our cash and do it in a low
risk way but not have to take the risk
of holding what our negative real
returning bonds then i think something
like stable coin yield generation
becomes really interesting they don't
take the price risk the price risk of
any digital asset and instead they still
have dollar exposure but they're able to
get higher rates of return something
like five six seven eight nine percent
some of these platforms are offering and
so when you start to think about a
business that says you know what our
cash management solution is no longer
going to be buying bonds or holding
other types of assets instead we simply
are going to convert electronic dollars
into digital dollars and then we are
going to put them into interest-bearing
accounts and we're going to generate
significant yield off of those assets
you can see a business that if they can
generate seven eight nine percent on
their cash position it could become a
pretty material revenue source think of
somebody like apple or berkshire
hathaway who sit on billions and
billions of dollars of cash
if they were to take a percentage of
that and to start to earn very high
rates of return you could see one not
only a continued normalization of the
industry
with public companies but also two
very quickly if you put 50 billion
dollars into one of these accounts you
could start to generate hundreds of
millions of dollars in annual income
that previously was not there it's
absolutely fascinating and so then when
if we go and we look at the companies
that have already bought bitcoin it's
clear that this is not going to reverse
this trend is only going to accelerate
from here so we've got macro strategy
which is a subsidiary of micro strategy
great naming by michael uh that holds
today let's see uh their cost basis is
200 uh 2.7 billion dollars the today
value uh is around 5 billion and they
hold over a hundred thousand bitcoin
tesla is next with about 43 000 bitcoin
their cost base is around 1.5 billion
today that value is over 2 billion not
including the piece that they sold and
then also square that's got about 8 000
bitcoin sitting on the balance sheet
they paid about 220 million and they're
up right around uh about 50 380 million
dollars or so of value and so what do we
think is this obviously the future and
every company is gonna end up doing this
or do we still have a long way to go to
get more and more companies to put
bitcoin or other assets on their balance
sheet from the crypto economy i mean i
think it starts with coinbase right like
brian armstrong the company was founded
in june 2012. he's obviously had deep
conviction in the digital asset space to
found a company in 2012 right bitcoin
was five dollars at the time right so
we're talking about uh almost a decade
ago at this point the ecosystem has
clearly developed over time and gotten
stronger uh but i think right like
coinbase is the type of company that you
expected to kind of do it at ipo i think
a lot of people were surprised they held
200 million dollars of bitcoin when they
ipo earlier this year a lot of money uh
but for an exchange that's been around
for 10 years and has been dealing in
those products i think people were
surprised that they didn't have more
but if you look at all the companies
that you just went through that have
done it so i just looked up previously
microstrategy has about five billion
dollars right you just said their stocks
up four hundred percent this year tesla
has about two billion their stocks up
seventy percent square has three hundred
and seventy five million their stocks up
seventy percent the s p is up forty
percent during that or 30 this year so
they've significantly outperformed all
of those uh the broader market
and yeah there's a bunch of it that goes
into tesla square microstrategy they're
all good foundational companies from
that standpoint but bitcoin has clearly
become a way to outperform and earn more
yields on your cash bitcoin is good for
business point-blank that's basically
what i'm trying to say bitcoin's up over
300 over the last 12 months yeah over
300 in the last 12 months if you start
to think about every single business
that put bitcoin on their balance sheet
it is very obvious that it helped
because it expanded that balance sheet
if you look at somebody like
microstrategy right over a year ago they
decided to convert 85 of their balance
sheet and now it's up more than 300
absolutely nuts now most of these
companies are not doing very high
percentages i do not think that we know
coinbase's balance sheet right now how
much of it is in bitcoin versus other
crypto assets versus u.s dollars that
would be very fascinating to know what
what the percentage breakdowns are and
then if you look at people like tesla
it's kind of high single digits and
square i think is kind of low single
digits it goes like two three percent
and so these still for the most part are
companies that are not going all in
they're not protecting the entire
balance sheet uh doing this or or kind
of putting their entire balance sheet in
instead what they're choosing to do is
these uh kind of smaller percentages i
do think though that the crypto
businesses the bitcoin miners that are
public all these types of businesses
they're the ones who are going to go
first and be super extreme obviously uh
over time though tesla's balance sheet
50 in bitcoin there's two ways we get
there they keep buying more and more and
more or they essentially just bought you
know single digits and bitcoin
appreciates so much that it grows to
become 50
if that happens elon musk looks like a
genius right jack dorsey looks like a
genius michael saylor already looks like
a genius because his balance sheet is
expanded you know hundreds of percent in
the 12-month period bitcoin is good for
business and i think that what we're
watching here uh is just another company
explicitly saying this is our strategy
and it feels like they're hitting the
gas pedal a little bit right because
they're not just doing bitcoin they're
doing the other assets and also they're
saying future profits we're going to
auto convert on a percentage basis to me
it's less about the 500 million purchase
and that's a very large purchase
especially for the amount of cash that
they have and their balance sheet but
it's also about the 10 that they said
they're gonna continuously buy quarter
by quarter right so well i think what
they're doing right is they're just
doubling down on their business model
essentially right they they bet on their
entire company was a leveraged bet on
the play that digital assets were going
to continue to grow and demand over time
right they built an exchange that you
could trade digital assets on so the
idea that they think digital assets will
continue to expand and demand will
continue to increase over time that's
obviously what they think right so when
you put it on the balance sheet you're
expressing that you think the price will
appreciate at the same time i think the
other thing that's interesting though is
that uh this is a way for companies to
get more institutional investments and
people are interested in their equity
right so when you think about
microstrategy uh and tesla and square
microstrategy they their investment base
expanded for companies that were looking
for exposure to digital assets and
specifically bitcoin that could not go
out and just buy the asset themselves
right so we've seen a bunch of companies
blackrock just invested uh millions and
millions of dollars in a couple mining
facilities here in the united states
right so that's getting exposure to the
asset class without going and actually
buying the asset itself microstrategy
has benefited from that tesla square all
these companies that benefit from that
coinbase is basically just a leveraged
bet on that same play i'll leverage play
on that same bet hey guys thanks so much
for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it